There's a very famous story about Canva.
Early on, you pitched over a hundred
investors and over a hundred investors
said no to you.
>> It was really clear in my mind that it
was the future and I thought the
investors were wrong, frankly. But
investors also gave really helpful
feedback and feedback often in the form
of rejection. They would say, "Oh, your
market's not big enough." And I would
say, "It's going to be huge." And I'd
add [music] a new page in my pitch deck
that said how big the market I believed
was. And then they'd say, "You're the
same as some other company." And I would
say, "Hey, now I've got a new slide in
my pitch deck that shows all the players
and the huge gap in the market that we
believe we're going going to fill."
>> One of your values, crazy big goals. I
love that as a value.
>> The thing that I love about a crazy big
goal is that you feel completely
inadequate before it. You want to work
really hard to will it into existence. I
really like to start by just imagining
what is the future that you actually
want. Right now, I have a wall in my
house in my office, which is my vision
for what [music] I'd like the world to
look like in 2050. I heard from one of
your HE members, Melissa Tan, that
there's a deck like this for every
project you kick off. There's this big
vision deck.
>> So, we have this concept of chaos to
clarity. Every idea starts in the chaos
side and then you have to work all the
way to the other side which is clarity.
That very first step at the far end of
chaos was quite a embarrassing step
actually because you don't have mastery
at that point. You don't have all the
answers. A lot of people think of Canva
as like a design graphics for, you know,
social media and and marketing and
things like that. But you also have
spreadsheets, docs, whiteboards, charts,
AI coding tool.
>> It was funny [music] looking back from
really old decks. We were trying to do
AI before AI was actually a thing.
>> Today, my guest is Melanie Perkins, CEO
and co-founder of Canva. Melanie is on
track to be the most successful female
tech founder in history and one of the
most successful founders, period. Canva
is currently valued at over $42 billion,
making over $3.3 billion in revenue a
year. They've been profitable for 8
years straight and are one of the
hottest private tech companies in the
world right now. But it wasn't always
this way. Melanie was rejected by over
100 investors when she was trying to
raise her first round. Their team spent
2 years rewriting their entire codebase
and were unable to ship any new features
for over 2 years, something they
expected to just take 6 months. and they
even went through a big pivot early on
from a yearbook publishing platform to
the Canva that you know today. Melanie
does not do a lot of podcasts. She
shares stories that I've never heard
before and lessons that I'm still
thinking about. This is a really rare
opportunity to learn from a legendary
founder. [music] A huge thank you to
Cameron Adams and Melissa Tan for
suggesting topics for this conversation.
If you enjoy this podcast, don't forget
to subscribe and follow it in your
favorite podcasting app or YouTube. And
if you become an annual subscriber of my
newsletter, you get a year free of 17
incredible products, including Devon,
lovable, replet, bolt, innate, and
linear, superhuman, descript, whisper
flow, gamma, perplexity, warp, granola,
magic pattern, raycast, jpd, and mobin.
Head on over to Lenny's newsletter.com
and click product pass. With that, I
bring you Melanie Perkins after a short
word from our sponsors. My podcast
guests and I love talking about craft
and taste and agency and product market
fit. You know what? We don't love
talking about sock 2. That's where Vanta
comes in. Vanta helps companies of all
sizes get compliant fast and stay that
way with industryleading AI automation
and continuous monitoring. Whether
you're a startup tackling your first
Sock 2 or ISO 2701 or an enterprise
managing vendor risk, Vanta's trust
management platform makes it quicker,
easier, and more scalable. Vanta also
helps you complete security
questionnaires up to five times faster
so that you can win bigger deals sooner.
The result, according to a recent IDC
study, Vanta customers slashed over
$500,000
a year and are three times more
productive. Establishing trust isn't
optional. Vanta makes it automatic. Get
$1,000 off at vanta.com/lenny.
Last year, 1.3% of global GDP flow
through Stripe. That's over $1.4
trillion. Stripe helps ambitious
founders start companies and scale them
from preede to IPO and beyond. Used by
78% of the Forbes AI50, Stripe provides
financial infrastructure for payments,
billing and software to platforms and
marketplaces so they can monetize
faster, experiment with pricing and grow
revenue. With Stripe, businesses achieve
massive global scale faster than they
would otherwise. And at the beginning of
that journey is where Stripe Startups
comes in. Stripe Startups is a program
designed to support early stage
ventureback businesses as they build,
iterate, and scale. Founders enrolled in
Stripe Startups get access to credits to
offset Stripe fees, expert insights, and
a focused community of other founders
building on Stripe. You can learn more
and apply for the program today at
stripe.com/startups.
Melanie, thank you so much for being
here and welcome to the podcast.
>> Thank you so much for having me. I'm
excited to be [music] here.
>> I'm even more excited. Uh it's such an
honor to have you here. I am such a fan
of yours. I'm such a fan of the company
that you've built. Also, just everyone I
meet from Canva is just like so nice and
so awesome and so smart. And so clearly,
you've built something really special.
Uh I'm really excited to use this hour
to learn as much as I can from you about
how you did that. And we were actually
chatting ahead of this about what would
make the best use of this hour. And I
asked you what you believe has been the
biggest factor in the success of Canva
and you described something called
building a column B company and column B
thinking. I've never heard of this
before. So let us start there. What is
what is what is building column B
company? What does that mean?
>> Really great place to start. So I guess
there's two ways of planning. The way
that um you can plan is you can dream of
like what is the perfect vision of the
future? What what future do you want to
exist in? What would you like the world
to look like? like what would you like
companies to look like and then going
from there which is completely
improbable, a completely crazy big dream
and then working hard to turn that into
reality. And the alternate is so you
know just imagine you you're building a
castle on the hill and you're like what
would be the most magical wonderful
mythical experience and the other thing
you can do is you can look at the bricks
around you and you can say what can I do
with these bricks how high can I stack
them what can I do and I think most
planning is often done by looking at the
bricks and trying to stack them and then
you kind of you know you can create only
so much and so I guess the column B
thinking is thinking about what is that
magical wonderful future that you then
want to invest years and decades of your
life actually building and so that's
column A and column B in a nutshell
>> so column A is the traditional just like
work from today's world column B is work
from this dream reality and work
backwards from how to achieve that
>> exactly that
>> this is exactly the way actually Brian
Chesky thought I worked at Airbnb for a
long time and it was always just like
think about the world the dream and then
work backwards from that so there's a
lot clearly also worked out so clearly
this is an important lesson in the
example of Canva just what is what would
have been column A for what Canva could
have been and what was the how did you
think about the column B approach of
what Canva in a dreamland could be.
>> So column A would have been nothing
frankly because you know the reality was
when I was a university student with no
company [laughter] and no business or
product or software experience the
reality would have been not not
[clears throat] very much. Um, and so it
was all column B. It was all thinking
about the wild future that we wanted to
create. You know, I imagined what would
be publishing in the future. What would
communications look like in the future?
Um, and it seemed really impossible that
it would stay on on the desktop. It
would stay really complicated. And it
just seemed so apparent to me that in
the future it was going to be de like
completely different. Could I build that
future? I had absolutely no idea. But
the idea
seemed completely
likely, completely improbable that it
wouldn't be the case that in the future
design would be online and collaborative
and really simple. And so starting from
that, we then took that concept and
applied it to the school yearbook market
in Australia uh with our first company,
Fusion Books. And then we applied it to
Canva uh where we wanted to take it much
much bigger.
>> Let's talk about just how to actually go
about building a column B company. Say a
founder's listening to this and they're
just like okay, I I want to do this.
What do they do? What are the steps?
Where do you start?
>> I really like to start by just imagining
what is the future that you actually
want? What is the world that you want to
live in? What is the future of
transportation? What is the future of
healthare? What is the future that you
want to live in and exist in? And you
know, for example, right now I have a
wall in my house with in my office which
is my vision for what I'd like the world
to look like in 2050. And so it's not
necessarily that you can bring that into
existence or you can will that into
existence, but just to start to get
clearer on what you would like that
world to be like. Would you like it to
be more inclusive? Would you like it to,
you know, for me, one of the things I
desperately want is everyone on this
planet to have their basic human needs
met. You know, what are those things
that you believe are so important that
you would love to see exist in that
future? And you know I think an exercise
we often do is like what is wild success
for X or what is wild success for Y and
then equally what is terrible failure
for those things and you can apply that
just to abstract thinking in different
industries you can do that apply that
for um we do that for the whole company
for different areas of the company and I
think just taking that very large long
time scale of 10 years um and getting a
really crisp idea of what you want and
what you don't done. That's sort of the
first step. And I think a lot of people
don't spend quite enough time imagining
that. And then the next part is you
don't want to just have this crazy big
dream um and then do nothing about
turning it into reality. You kind of
want to have a ladder that goes all the
way up to the moon, which is your crazy
wild vision and then you want to have
rungs that just like work its way up
step by step. And so you want to get
that really clear picture of the future
that you would like and then just take
little step after little step after
little step. And it doesn't matter how
small that first step is or how you
seemingly inconsequential. If it is
working towards that future that you
want to will into existence, then you'll
keep on climbing up that ladder in the
right direction.
>> I think a lot of people hearing this
might feel like I do this. Yeah, I have
a vision. I kind of I know where I'm
going. I have this big idea. What do you
think they might be missing about just
what this actually means and why they're
probably not thinking big enough?
They're not making the time to think
like this. I think it is
easy to be discouraged by the two
because they're completely two complete
odds like they're completely different
ends of the spectrum. So one is dreaming
about the future. Not that you think you
can will into existence, just the future
that you want. And then the next part is
taking the tiny step that might be
extremely microscopic. And it feels a
little embarrassing to be like I want a
future that is, you know, whatever it
might be and then to take such a
microscopic step because I think you
often have the future in one side or
don't spend much time thinking about
that. You're just thinking about the
bricks before you. And so I think it's
also, you know, naturally we all get
distracted by day-to-day, you know, it's
your your email, your Slack, the things
that are kind of in your face, you know,
the reality that lives around you every
day that kind of pulls you into this
moment right now. And so I think
actually just making time to spend
thinking about that is probably one of
the most critical pieces. Like just
literally dreaming like what is wild
success in 10 years? What is terrible
failure in 10 years? um is a really
great place to start is just like
spending some time there and then like
even if that is so big and so vast and
so wild having that very first step is
so important because then you take that
little tiny first step and then the next
step and then that compounds you know
for us it's been compounding over a
decade as we continue to work towards
that same mission and vision.
>> I want to hear how you operationalize
this. I heard from one of your team
members, uh, Melissa Tan, that there's a
deck like this for every project you
kick off. There's this big vision deck
that talk about what that looks like
because I think that's where people are
like, "Okay, how do I actually do this?"
Talk about that deck.
>> So, we have this concept of chaos to
clarity. Um, and every idea starts in
the chaos side and then you have to work
all the way to the other side, which is
clarity. And so, chaos can be an idea,
it can be a problem, it can be a
philosophy or a belief. And um I've got
a joke that I find funny. I'm not sure
if you will, but [laughter] how do you
add how do you go from chaos to clarity?
>> You add clarity. And so the idea is that
like each like little step from chaos to
clarity is like the very first step
might be literally writing it down. So
rather than it being in your head,
you've written it down. Then the next
step might be um starting to create a
pitch deck on on it. And the next step
might be starting to refine that,
turning it into some designs, turning it
into a prototype. And then as it kind of
goes from chaos to clarity, it starts to
become more and more real and more and
more people can see it. And so just like
taking those little incremental steps
that adds clarity with every single step
then starts to help will it into
existence rather than it being something
that's completely amorphous and just
stays in your head. So I think that's
why, you know, visual communication for
us is so important is because otherwise
if it's just in your head, no one else
can see it and you can't will it into
existence. This makes me think about
this concept of an ugly baby from the
book Creativity Inc. by I think Ed
Catmull where he talks about how new
ideas are this ugly baby that nobody
wants to look at and deal with that and
like I think he says they want to kill
that why we do that with ugly baby. Uh
but there are these like very soft
subtle uh uh fragile things and it's
really important to not kill them early
and give them chance to survive. And
it's kind of what I'm hearing here is
like have this big vision that many
people would be like no way this is
completely absurd. And I love this idea
of okay but here's like one step we
could take there to see if this could be
a thing.
>> Yeah, I completely agree. And I think
that's the thing is that the that very
first step at the very like far end of
chaos, it's very embarrassing because
you're like, I have this idea that is so
big and so wild and how the hell would I
do that? I have no idea. And so it's
quite a embarrassing step actually. Um
because you don't have mastery at that
point. You don't have all the answers.
In fact, you have likely not none of the
answers, but you just have the idea that
you think would be cool. And ideally,
you get the idea that would be so cool
that you want to work really hard to
will that into existence. And so, I
think one of the really key parts is not
only just having the idea, but thinking
it's so cool that you're going to work
for years to will it into existence.
Actually, Melissa did a really amazing
pitch deck recently about the vision of
uh I won't go into the details right
here, but the vision of her space, and I
was really excited about it. Um, and so
I think that that's the great thing
about a pitch deck is that other people
can see your thinking and your thinking
actually gets clarified as well as you
go through that process.
>> I talked to Melissa, I talked to a bunch
of other people that work at Canva that
have worked at Canva. And something else
I heard along these lines is this phrase
crazy big goals, which I think is one of
your values. Crazy big goals. I love
that as a value. Why is that so
important? How does that fit into this?
And just talk about the uh the power of
having crazy big goals.
>> Yeah. So right from the start of Canva,
it was truly a crazy big goal. We're
like, we want to empower the world to
design and take all these things that
are super complicated and put them into
one platform and make it accessible to
the whole world and we want to rather
than it be super expensive and
unaffordable, we want to empower
everyone everywhere in the world to
design. So I mean that was the epitome
of a crazy big goal and you know if we
macro out even further, we've got this
two-step plan, build one of the world's
most valuable companies and do the most
good we can do. So again, a rather crazy
big goal. Um, and I think the thing that
I love about a crazy big goal is that
you feel completely inadequate before
it. Um, you know, another crazy big goal
would love to see everyone's basic human
needs met on the planet. Like completely
crazy big. That truly shouldn't be. Um,
it's kind of absolutely absurd that
that's the case, but we can go into that
later. Um, but I think with a crazy big
goal, then you want to work really hard
to will it into existence. And so if you
start with a reasonable goal or a
realistic goal, then you kind of get to
get to it and you're like, "Oh, cool,
whatever." Or more importantly, if
something happens, you know, all the
problems and roadblocks come along as
they always do, then you're like, "Okay,
I I won't bother with that." And then
you can just like go and choose another
course. And so a crazy big goal is both
crazy big, but it's also something that
you think is incredibly important that
you actually want to will into existence
because it is so much work to will a
crazy big goal into existence. So it
better be one that you want to actually
achieve.
>> Is there a crazy big goal that you set
that comes to mind maybe as a good
example of this is what I'm talking
about. Maybe a product you launched or
feature back in the day.
>> Yeah, I mean so many things. So we have
um um our mission empower the world to
design and we break it down into mission
pillars. So empower everyone to design
anything with every ingredient in every
language on every device. Obviously a
mouthful but then what we do is we take
successive goals every year towards this
mission. And so for designing anything,
we started off with social media and you
know presentations and now and like docs
and websites and whiteboards and video
and so every year we're just launching
more and more things to fulfill that
part of the mission of empowering
everyone to design anything and then
equally in every language we started in
English and then it was Spanish and then
it was 20 languages and then 100
languages and then hard languages like
Arabic and Hebrew and Erdo and you know
right to left languages and now you know
we're in 100 plus languages now and now
we're really doubling down in the
localization experience to make it feel
truly local in every market around the
world. And so you can see how having
these very big audacious goals that you
then just like take a step after step um
towards helps then will it into
existence or on every device. We started
off obviously just with a web platform
and then we launched our iPad app and
then iPhone and then Android and then we
spent years investing in crossplatform.
So we have the same feature set across
every device. And so you can see how
these like big amorphous things that
seem very outlandish you can then just
will into existence after continual
investment for a decade and it compounds
over time.
>> I see how all this is starting to fade
together. There's this big crazy
ambitious vision and below there are the
mission pillars that are feeding into
this vision and then the crazy big goals
within each of those mission pillars to
measure your progress towards all these
uh components of the mission.
>> Exactly.
>> Um okay. So with all that in mind,
there's also this kind of trade-off you
have to make of just how ambitious you
get because oftentimes sometimes maybe
you never miss a goal but most many
times people miss these very ambitious
goals. How do you just find that balance
between ambitious crazy but doable
enough where people don't get
discouraged? I think with a crazy big
goal, the thing we have been really
great at is achieving them. The time
frame that we achieved them on has not
always been uh very reliable. We have
certainly not been able to have ping
dart. What's the what's it accur?
>> We have not been very accurate with
timing. But it's really interesting. I
looked back at a 2021 2021 vision deck
that we made obviously in 2021, but it
was about 2026 and it was fascinating to
see how much we'd actually been able to
achieve from that vision deck and how
many things were currently still in
flight. And so by having that I thought
in 2021 some of those things may have
happened a little quicker but over the
over the you know last five years
they've really been coming into reality
and so you know we might think things
are going to take six months and they
take a year we might think things are
going to take six months and they take
two years as has been the case. We might
think something's actually going to take
our entire lifetime as some of those
really truly crazy big goals. And in
fact, I don't even know if we can ever
achieve them, frankly, but they're such
an important goal that even if you make
a little step in their direction,
they're worthwhile nonetheless.
>> Whether you like him or not, Elon, this
is similar to his um if you watch him,
he has sets these really ambitious goals
and then often is far late on achieving
them, but clearly it has worked out in
achieving the crazy things that he's
achieved. Something else I hear is you
celebrate these goals in a really unique
way to um talk about that.
>> So when we have these crazy be goals, we
also have couple them with really fun
celebrations. And so we attempt to make
the crazy big goals happen in a moment
in time. So then when we achieve them,
we actually have a really fun moment. Um
because if you're just trying to plot
towards the top of the mountain always
and you never like take a little moment
to pat yourself on the back, it would
feel a little arduous. And so, you know,
over the years we had all sorts of fun
little celebrations where, you know, we
have smashed Greek plates and released
doves and had a little automatina
festival and
>> oh wow,
>> you know, all sorts of fun things just
to take a moment with the team to
celebrate that huge achievement. Um, and
so I think that that's, you know, you
want to celebrate what you want to um
really focus on and what you want
everyone to take that moment. So when
you achieve that crazy big goal when we
launch in Spanish, when we hit a hundred
languages, you know, and then the so
forth across the company, taking that
moment to actually pat yourself on the
back and pat the teams on the back and
say, "Hey, we did this thing." Um, that
thing that seemed really hard, we've now
achieved. And you know, the mission is
often, you know, each of the different
mission pillars, they're obviously a
long area of investment that's going to
take a long time to get to, but being
able to celebrate each of the the rungs
on that um on the way there, I think is
extraordinarily important. And then it
makes everyone um you know, everyone
works extraordinarily hard to bring them
to life and then it gives everyone a
little moment to to feel proud of
themselves.
>> It'd be very motivating to get to just
break a bunch of plates. I really like
that. [laughter]
>> We need to bring that one back. We
haven't done that one in a while.
It's a good one. Uh I just love how
concrete you're making this. So it's,
you know, set these crazy big goals,
find the components of the goals, set
numbers there, and then figure out kind
of the steps you take to achieve these
things. All feels very easy. Kind of on
the flip side of that, this is a segue.
Uh people hear these stories, they hear
your story, they see Canva over the
years, and it's just this like up and to
the right huge success story, one of the
most successful companies in history. I
imagine there have been many periods
where things weren't going so great and
when maybe things didn't look like they
worked would work out. So let me just
ask you this. over the over the course
of building Canva once it started to
click and started to feel like it was
going to be a thing was there a point
where it started to again feel like wow
maybe this may not work out maybe
there's a huge setback that we may not
get over
>> I think it's just a constant evolution
like every time the company doubles in
size pretty much all your systems break
all the things that were working don't
work you know a little example in the
early days we'd stand up and everyone
would present their um present their
goals what they're working on every day
or every week and then it kind of moved
every month and then it was just like it
was just taking too long because we've
got so many people and then it was sort
of like we started doing these things
called season openers and season openers
were really fun where we got the entire
company together we talked about the
goals that we'd achieved and it was so
funny because ahead of season openers
everyone would launch everything because
they wanted to do it ahead of the season
opener and then we'd also set the goals
for the coming cycle or for the coming
season at that point in time but then
they started to become like six hours
because we had so many people and so
many teams and so like trying to find
that right uh just with the same
philosophies of deep context for
everyone um with the same philosophies
of the celebrations and the goals and
like trying to find that right flavor at
every stage of scale is definitely hard
and so I think it's just like a constant
work in progress or you know back to
your earlier point about timing of
things we were doing a front-end rewrite
and we thought it take about 6 months.
It was really important because it was
critical for crossplatform. It was
critical for right to left. It was
critical because we could only have five
people working in our editor at any
point in time because of the way the
code base was structured and we thought
it was going to take six months and then
it took two years and um it was two
years of not shipping any product, two
years of a product company not being
able to ship product and like that is
such a core motivation for our team is
like shipping something, seeing great
customer feedback, you know, and then
that kind of makes everyone feel happy
and like you've got momentum. them and
it just felt like we're in a dark dark
tunnel. um that we could hardly see the
end of the tunnel and we didn't really
know how long it was going to take
because it just had to take as long as
the tunnel was going to take and it was
you know a very hard time because you
know other people would be launching
this and that and it was we weren't you
know eventually we got out of that
tunnel and it was extremely important
that we did that work. We've now got two
and a half thousand engineers and we're
able to deliver amazing things that
would have just like been completely
infeasible but and and simultaneous
collaboration was all like so many
things were baked into this but yeah it
was not a fun period of time. A product
company not shipping product [laughter]
is not really a recipe for fun
>> for two years. for two years.
>> I feel like every builder listening to
this knows exactly what you've been
through and maybe not in that scale and
those stakes, but you start on
something. Oh yeah, it'll be take a few
weeks and then a year later you're still
working on it.
>> Totally.
>> How did it just was the mood really uh I
don't know sad internally? Just that
must have been like two years. That's a
a long time not to ship anything. Just
what was it like internally during that
period?
>> I think it was kind of everything
internally like we we we made it into a
bit of a game. We had this game board
and I I bought these little like rubber
ducky sort of bath toys and we had this
um so we had all the little the
components represented as a bath toy on
this um board and there was like all
these stages of like home uh kind of
went launched in product. There was an
emergency lane. At the end of it was
home and hosed and we like did these
weekly standups where everyone would
come in and talk where their bath toy
was at. And kind of just like we tried
to make it fun and for the team. So it
was partly fun [laughter] and it was
partly distressing um as all of our
investors were like hey you know that
thing. [laughter] Um so I think it was
it was it was both things at the same
time. It was bonding let's say.
>> Okay. Speaking of investors, speaking of
other hard times, there's a very famous
story about Canva. Early on, you pitched
uh over a hundred investors and over a
hundred investors said no to you when
you were just starting Canva. Uh that's
I think that's more the investors than
any founder I've talked to like actually
tries to pitch. It's a it's impressive
you tried that hard and went for so many
pitches and finally got someone to take
a bet. Now you are something like a $40
billion company making 3.3 billion ARR.
Uh, I think there's something like 240
million monthly active users. One of the
hottest private companies in the world.
Just how does how does this feel?
>> I don't know. It was really clear in my
mind that it was the future and I
thought the investors were wrong,
frankly. Um, but investors also gave
really helpful feedback and feedback
often in the form of rejection. So, they
would say, "Oh, your market's not big
enough." And I would say, "It's going to
be huge." And I'd add a new page in my
pitch deck that said how big the market
I believe was. And then they'd say,
"You're the same as some other company."
And I'd say, "And that coupled with
rejection." And I would say, "Hey, now
I've got a new slide in my pitch deck
that shows all the all the players and
the huge gap in the market that we
believe we're going going to fill." Or
most investors just knew absolutely
nothing about design or the industry
that we're in. And so we then ended up
with the first few slides saying,
"Here's the the lay of the land today.
Here's the problem that we're going to
solve." And so while it was
extraordinarily frustrating,
their feedback made us stronger and made
our pitch deck stronger. And it was sort
of like, you know, from that chaos to
clarity at the start it was this like
this idea and then through the copious
amounts of rejection, the pitch deck got
stronger and more refined. So then when
people, you know, the first time I
remember I spoke to someone for hours
and they eventually got it. They were
really committed to understanding what
we were trying to do. But then not
everyone has six hours to understand a
concept. And so being able to take all
the gems of wisdom from that
conversation and have that understood
really clearly in a really short period
of time and have all of the reasons that
people were rejecting us pre-answered in
that that initial pitch deck was really
important. And I think that's probably
one of the reasons why, you know, when I
look back at our 2012 pitch deck, it's
so valid and really still captures what
we're doing today. And so I think that
rejection in some ways makes you
stronger if you can persist through.
>> Well, I think beyond that, I've never
heard this part of the story. It's not
just persisting, it's actually iterating
and and uh taking feedback that you're
hearing to continue to evolve the pitch
to a place where okay, I finally get
what you're doing. Uh that is such a
cool part of the story. Is there how
much of the product like how much of
that vision and product changed
throughout that journey versus just the
way you pitched it and and convinced
people?
>> It was pretty consistent, but the way we
articulated it changed greatly. And so
for example, I wouldn't in in the early
days articulate the problem very much. I
spent into like here's the cool
solution. And so then the first few
pages became very much more problem
based. So because if people don't
understand the problem then they can't
understand or care about your solution.
And so there was a lot of a lot of
[snorts] refinement on the way it was
articulated and but the actual vision
itself I think was pretty consistent
through. I'm uh guessing a lot of
founders ask for your advice on raising
money, getting started, having gone
through so much rejection early on. What
do you what's your general advice to
folks that are having a hard time
fundraising?
>> I mean, I can only go on my experience,
but I think
it's sort of like the dark tunnel
analogy just or chaos to clarity. Let's
go read that one. It's a slightly
friendlier analogy. And I think just
taking the rejection and turning into
things that you can control. So, I can
control my pitch deck. I can control the
number of people I'm speaking to and I
just spoke to literally everyone. And I
think that like continuing to use it to
refine it rather than taking it as a
personal rejection. I think it's really
important to think like how can I
improve? How can I help someone to
understand it? Some people are never
going to understand it. I remember
pitching an investor that had the lean
startup book on their on behind them
when they were when I was pitching them
and um they were never going to like
Canva because we were not the lean
startup. that was not the way that we're
approaching it whatsoever. So, there's
some people that are just going to never
like you and that's okay. I think it's
important to find some people that do
like what you're trying to say and
trying to do. Um, and you know, kind of
finding your tribe. I think
>> I think as an investor, this is really
interesting to hear because it tells you
there are companies like Canva out there
that everyone's turning down, hundred
investors passed on that you might still
be able to invest in.
Talking about your growth as a leader,
say if you compare Melanie of today to
Melanie of I don't know 12 13 years ago
when you were just starting Canva, what
would you say is most different in terms
of uh leadership?
>> I don't really know. Probably if you ask
other people around me, they'd probably
be more observant. Um, but it is funny
because there's some things that I think
that I need to change and then I realize
like, you know, go into it the same as
some other company and sometimes we even
try that for a while and then we we try
that out and we're like that's, you
know, it didn't really work for us. And
it's kind of like building a house that
you want every brick in the house to
match. And if you go and try and take
some bricks from someone else's house
and stick it in your house, it's
probably going to not look very matched.
And so trying to find things that are
authentic to us and are authentic to the
you know everything that's come before
it is just that constant constant thing
and like then each scale of each you
know stage of scale of the company
rather than going taking someone else's
bricks and trying to stick that in in
your house um trying to build the thing
that's authentic. So, I think there's
many things that are the same, but
obviously the stage and scale and the,
you know, we're constantly having to
give away hats. And so, I you kind of
think about it in the very early days
where just a few of us or just two of us
in in fusion and then three of us and
just a little tiny group and you kind of
wear a hundred hats and then you have to
be able to give away those hats to other
people that can then do that way better
than yourself. And so I'm sure there's
been a few skills I guess I would have
had to have developed over the last
decade um to be able to give away those
hats. But yeah, I think there's a lot of
things that we've had to do and double
down on that was more authentic to the
way we um way we did it in the early
days actually.
>> I I love that story. I think again if
anyone working at a company that has
gone through a lot of growth has
experienced that when people from other
companies come in and here's how we did
it at this company. Is there is there an
example of some there that just like
here's something that this company
brought in and people from this company
thought we should do and we tried and
didn't work. I won't go into specific
examples but so many times over and I
think that I mean maybe that's probably
in answer to your other question like
not have we did things our way because
that was the only way we knew and there
was many many times over the years that
we're like didn't have confidence in the
way we were doing things and we were
like oh they they've done it from a big
company that's bigger than our company
let's go do that and that hasn't always
worked out so well for us and so yeah I
think confidence in how we take what is
authentic to us and do it at the next
level of scale is a constant work in
progress. It feels like, you know, as I
was saying before, systems break and
need to be reinvented, but also
reimagined for that next layer of scale
rather than going to try to get
something off the shelf from another
company.
>> I imagine it also helped that you were
in Australia away from the Bay Area and
and where all these other, you know, big
companies are at, just being being able
to do it your own way.
>> Yeah, very much so. Did you know that I
have a whole team that helps me with my
podcast and with my newsletter? I want
everyone on that team to be super happy
and thrive in their roles. Just Works
knows that your employees are more than
just your employees. They're your
people. My team is spread out across
Colorado, Australia, Nepal, West Africa,
and San Francisco. My life would be so
incredibly complicated to hire people
internationally, to pay people on time
and in their local currencies, and to
answer their HR questions 24/7. But with
Just Works, it's super easy. Whether
you're setting up your own automated
payroll, offering premium benefits, or
hiring internationally, Just Works
offers simple [music] software and 24/7
human support from small business
experts for you and your people. They do
your human resources right so that you
can do right by your people. Just works
for your people.
Is there anything else that is a good
example of how you did something pretty
different from how other companies
operate? Anything else that comes to
mind as a as a fun example?
>> The goal driven structure. I think you
know the things that we were talking
about before. So the mission actually
breaking that down into the mission
pillars. Breaking those mission pillars
down into the goals that we're then
pursuing and then celebrating those
goals when we do achieve them I think is
a deeply underloved uh way of building a
company. Often people have a mission
that's kind of on the wall somewhere and
then what they're actually doing and the
way they actually make money and the way
that you know the where people actually
spend their time is in a very very
different direction from that original
that original mission and I think the
magic is when you can bring those two
things together and so you can have your
mission you can have your mission
pillars that actually are helping to
achieve that and I think there's a real
authenticity in that for customers as
well is that you're actually doing the
thing that you promise you do and it all
ladders up together. Um, it's certainly
not an easy way to run a company. But I
think that when you do get that formula
right, I think that there's a a lot of
authenticity with what you're saying
you're doing, you're actually doing.
>> I want to come back to that. That's a
whole uh really cool process you have
with closing the loop with customers.
But something else I want to talk about
while we're in this topic of growth over
time. Uh, I saw you post something about
how you had to realize they had to slow
down and not just work work like crazy.
talk about just that realization and why
that ended up being so valuable. So in
the early days I would just work seven
days a week round the clock. You know in
our very first company we actually had
printing presses because we were
printing the yearbooks in my mom's house
and then delivering them into schools
around Australia. And you know in the
early days of Canva we certainly you
know were working all weekend all hours
of the day. It was just constant. Um,
but when you've been doing this for a
while, if you just keep working at that
pace, you know, I don't think it's good
for anyone's health, mental health, or
any anything else. So I think finding
ways to
continue like you know I still work
extraordinarily hard but to continue to
have that balance in my dayto-day where
I actually go to sleep I you know I find
time to do things like going for walks
or doing yoga um journaling I find
extraordinarily helpful um to make sure
that I can always bring my best to
everything that I'm doing.
>> It's uh it's easy to say that kind of
stuff. It must be really hard to
actually make time for that thing. Is
there anything for those sorts of
things? Is there anything that you do
that allows you to actually protect that
time to actually do these things?
Because, as you said, there's a billion
things that are just looking for your
attention constantly.
>> I feel like I've developed some healthy
habits over the years. I don't have
email or Slack on my phone and so when I
shut my laptop, I actually tune out and
then if there's a real issue, I'll get
an emergency call or page. [laughter]
Um, but I think trying to delineate, I
think, is really important. So when I'm
working, I'm all in. And then when I'm
not working, I'm all out. And actually
giving that mental space, I think, is
really important. I've spoken to a lot
of founders that haven't quite found
that. And then do struggle with it, you
know? So when they're not when they're
working every weekend, it feels like the
right thing, but then you're kind of
missing sometimes you can miss the
forest from the trees when you're just
working harder and harder, but maybe
you're actually working on the wrong
thing. And so I think being able to step
away a little just to be able to get
perspective to be a is actually really
beneficial.
>> I want to come back to this closing the
loop uh process let's say is that you
have where you uh figure out what to
build a lot a lot of your ideas come
actually from the community. Talk about
just that process and how many of your
ideas actually came from your community.
>> Oh it's been one of my favorite things.
We've been doing it for years now. And
so we get more than a million requests
from our community every year. And we
then we've got a whole incredible team
that then tallies them um breaks them
down and then delivers them to all of
our product teams. And then those
actually get closed. So this year we've
closed more than 200 loops. But we know
that each one of those things is going
to be loved and needed by so many more
people that don't bother to actually
fill out the request form. And so so
many things from gradient text like
little things like gradient text to
really big things like our sheets
product there's just been countless
products you know in the early days with
our AI products we didn't release them
to teachers because we knew there was a
lot of hesitancy for um teachers using
AI in the classroom and we got so many
requests from teachers saying can I
please use this magic right in the
classroom and so then we um unlocked
that and put on safety controls for
teachers and so it's just constant
actually it's just part of our product
process. I think there's two parts to
product. One is building the future um
and towards the mission and the the
mission pillars as I was saying before
and the other is actually listening to
our community and building what they
want. And so I think that that's the two
core pieces of product in my mind and
you know there's so the closing the loop
comes in so many different forms.
There's the explicit asks and then the
other thing that we double down on all
the time is user testing and watching
people use it and if people hesitate
clicking a button or people don't quite
understand how something works. It's
amazing to me how you can find 10 random
people on the internet and they can give
such astute feedback that then is so
representative for such a large number
of people. So I've personally run
hundreds if not thousands of user tests
um myself and it's been deeply embedded
in our product teams also. Wow, that
must be really stressful for someone uh
looking at a test of Canva trying to try
someone when you're in the room.
>> It's actually we do it all online
actually. We I I mean, well, the ones
I've run are are typically online. So,
people are so much more frank, I think,
when they just it's just them and their
camera and they don't really um
>> yeah, they they tell you really how it
is.
>> Is there a tool or a kind of a process
there that you find really helpful? I
don't know if you want to name names of
products or anything like that, but it's
something that you find helpful or
useful. Yeah, we use a lot of user
testing.com. I find that super super
valuable.
>> All right, go user testing. Okay,
something else that I know is really
important to you and also really unique
to Canva is something that's called the
two-step plan. You mentioned this
earlier. Uh I want to definitely talk
about this. What is the two-step plan?
Why is this so important to you?
>> Yeah, so when you were asking about
crazy goals, I think this is our most
macro, most crazy biggest goal. Step
one, build one of the world's most
valuable companies. and step two do the
most good we can do. And in our early
days, I thought I'd do step one and then
step two. And
realized that actually step one can fuel
step two and step two can fuel step one.
And so that's been a really big part of
Canva for some years now. You know, in
the early days we took the 1% pledge,
which I think is an incredible program.
Every single person, every single
company should should take that where
you give 1% of time, money, equity, and
um profitability. And I think that's a
really easy thing to do in the early
days that then can compound greatly over
time. We also knew that Canvas equity
was obviously going to be a really key
part of it. So, um, Cliff and I owned
um, a little over 30% of Canva. And so,
we decided we're going to take 30% of
Canva and do use it to do the most good
we can do. And we are doing that. So,
we're doing all of our donating through
the Canva Foundation. We've just over
the last few years we've um donated $50
million to give directly where they give
money directly to people in Malawi who
are in extreme poverty and then they can
use that money um on their family to go
to school, to get health care, to start
small businesses, to get a roof so they
can sleep in without being wet. Um you
know, just like real truly basic human
needs things. Um and we've just
announced that we're going to be um
giving another hundred million dollars
over the next four years um to people in
extreme poverty. And it's just like when
you go and sit with people and you hear
about how they're spending, you know,
what's very microscopic amount at $550
is, you know, doesn't buy us that much,
but it's a life-changing amount of money
for for people in extreme poverty. And
it's truly transformational what it can
do. And you know, you meet people and
you hear their stories and it's truly
the best money I could ever imagine
spending. And you know that crazy big
dream I was mentioning earlier of
everyone having basic human needs met.
It's so completely insane that that
isn't the case today. There's no
specific reason why people don't have
their basic human needs met on our
planet. But we just haven't got our act
together as humanity. And so that is a
truly crazy big dream. But back to the
two-step plan. Step one, build one of
one of the world's most valuable
companies. And step two, do the most
good we can do. And you know, finding
ways to do that at the same time, I
think is extraordinarily important.
>> That's incredible. It makes me think
about um not to mention Elon again, but
Elon's three-step strategy plan, and
it's like build better cars versus this
is like, okay, solve all the problems of
the world and and make the world a
better place. What a better master plan
to compare.
And something else about this that I
love is a lot of companies have this
have something philanthropic going on
with the company and it's like sitting
in a dock on some page. It's part of
their mission. It's not actually that
big of a deal to them. What I hear from
folks at Canvas is something you talk
about all the time. This is like an
actually core part of how you work and
think and how you set goals and set
vision and missions.
>> Yeah, I'm happy to hear that. I wouldn't
do Canva if it wasn't going to have a
positive impact on the world. Like for
me, getting really rich is not a goal
unto itself whatsoever. It's a means to
an end. And you know, I've been very
blessed to be able to do some work and
that creates wealth that can then go and
have people's basic human needs met. You
know, it's completely Yeah. But they
they're working just as hard, but they
don't have the opportunity. And you
know, even our education product is now
used by 100 million people each month.
and we are in, you know, most school
districts and rolled out across
countries and being able to bring
quality education tools to every and we
give that away for free as well. Giving
um being able to help empower schools
all around the world and we're going to
be doubling down and doubling down into
that product to bring quality education
to all. I think it's it gives so much
more meaning behind work. You know,
we've also between our education product
and our nonprofit program where we also
give away our paid product for free.
We've we're giving away $ 1.5 billion
dollars of product a year now. And so
the impact that that can have and the
ripple effect of that I think is pretty
great. And I think for all of us it
gives a lot more meaning to our work
than you know get rich.
>> Okay. So speaking of product coming back
to that you guys are launching something
maybe you've already launched it by the
time this comes out. Uh what I heard
described as the the the biggest launch
in Canvas's history. No big deal. That's
a high bar considering all the things
you guys have launched. What are you
launching? Why is it such a big deal? So
we are extraordinarily excited about
what we are launching. We I guess the
whole mission of Canva is to empower the
world to design and so what has been
enabled by new technology with all of AI
has been just really profound enabled
enabling people to take their idea and
turn it into design a design and have as
little friction between those two
points. So we are doubling down
radically on our video product and bring
some incredible capabilities to our
mobile and desktop platform. We are um
launching email which has been one of
our most hotly requested features um
from enterprise customers around the
world and business customers around the
world who want to be able to design with
Canvas drag and drop ease and to be able
to create an email. We're launching
forms. We are launching probably one of
the most exciting things is the way
we're embedding AI across the entire
product suite. And so you can actually
um use AI to design a presentation, a
video, a um email, a website. All of
these things can actually now be done
inside the core editor inside the design
tab. Um which is used by 170 million
it's used 170 million times a month. And
then on our elements tab, which is used
900 million times a month, um we are
also embedding AI. So you can actually
generate a video, you can generate a um
Canva code and you can generate photos
all directly inside that platform. And
then we're also launching comments as
you lots of use our customers use Canva
um to comment and collaborate. And now
you can actually just tag at Canva and
you can collaborate um you can just say
hey like can you make this title
shorter? Can you do this? Can you do
that? And it has all of the context of
the design. So in situ you can actually
just have a collaborator that can help
get your work done. So, we are pretty
excited about all of this.
>> Amazing. I something I'm going to just
let people know. I don't know if people
know all this, how many products you all
have now. I think a lot of people think
of Canva as like a design graphics for,
you know, social media and and marketing
and things like that. But you also have
spreadsheets, docs, whiteboards, charts,
uh code, AI coding tool, and now uh what
I'm hearing is email forms. There's
probably a few other things I'm not
thinking.
>> Yeah. Truly design anything. We're
literally living up to that. Like 100
million people design a presentation in
Canva each month now. And it's it's
pretty fascinating to see that when you
speak to I saw a tweet some time ago
that they were talking about how it's a
generational thing that a certain
generation uses Microsoft a generation
uses Google and then Gen Z like
presentations have become the way they
design a presentation is in Canva. Um,
but it's not just generational for those
of other other generational ilk. Uh, but
it's it's it's been fascinating to to
see that come to life.
>> The email product, is that like a email
client product or it's a design emails
that you can then send through your
products?
>> It is design emails. So, you can design
email, then you can take that code and
you can pop it into any pla email
platform that you use.
>> How do you think about products you're
going to expand to? I know there's like
trade secrets here. You don't want to
tell everyone where you're going next,
but just how do you approach here's
where we're going next? So our mission
empower world design empower everyone to
design anything with every ingredient in
every language on every device and just
take those things very literally. So to
literally design anything to literally
um publish anywhere and so you know we
now print in
oh 50 something countries around the
world and you can get it printed
delivered to your your house and we've
planted
>> I actually did that while you're out
here.
>> Awesome. I have that's ran. I wasn't
planning this, but I got a print thing
delivered to my house. So cool. Like we
have to go to a print shop in this
freaking graphic and then Well, look at
this button. Let's click.
>> Exactly. You just click print and it
pops up beautifully packaged to your
door.
>> I don't know how that works. Yeah. I
don't know how you do that, but it
worked. How cool.
>> That is very cool. And so yeah, I guess
literally bring these things to life.
Oh, we're like launching 3D as well. So
like e all of these things um we will be
bringing to life literally and just
picking off like what is the most
strategically important next thing um to
en enable everyone to design anything to
enable everyone to publish anywhere um
and we have been doing that for a decade
and we'll continue to do that forever
more using the latest technology to
truly bring people's ideas to life.
Okay, so this is helpful. So if
someone's like, "Oh, well will Canva
come for my my space?" It's Are there
people designing things? That was design
and also what was it? Publish.
>> Publishing anywhere.
>> Okay. Publishing and designing. Okay. So
if you're doing any designing or
publishing, [laughter]
watch out.
>> From a macro perspective, there was um
creativity tools and productivity tools.
And what Canva really does is we're
literally smack bang in the middle of
that ven diagram of creativity and
productivity rather than making our
customers have to make a choice between
those two tools two suites.
>> Something I wasn't planning on asking
about, but I think it's on everyone's
minds. There's always this like Figma
and Adobe and then there's Canva and
there's kind of a bunch of places we
could go with this. One is just at the
beginning of the journey where a lot of
founders try to figure out their wedge
and their specific niche. Just how did
you think about that? like here's how we
might have a chance to I know Fig wasn't
even around back then I don't think just
like how did you approach your early
wedge of users
>> one of the most important things that we
did was we didn't really worry about
competitors at all we actually just saw
where is there a gap in the market that
we can uniquely fill and what can we
solve a problem a core problem that
people currently have today and so with
our first company that was yearbooks in
Australia and there wasn't great tools
and these yearbook coordinators got
thrown in to have to design something
and you they'd have no design experience
and you know we spoke to every single
customer. We gave them an over the phone
tutorial. We understood all of their
pain points. We got continuous customer
feedback and then we try to iterate and
improve. And then when we were thinking
about Canva or a few years into that
actually one of the schools said, "I
love this product so much. Can I use it
to design newsletters?" And you know,
they had all sorts of other things that
they wanted to use it for. And we kind
of looked around and were like, "Oh,
like there's still nothing on the
market." this was like a few years into
it that actually does the thing that
we're doing but for all these other
things and so it was it was much more
like where is the gap in the market that
people are currently having a painoint
and if you can solve that painoint
really well and solve it in such a way
that people actually want to pay for it
because they it is truly solving a real
painoint that they have I think that
kind of sets it up for success rather
than um be a problem or a solution
looking for a problem. So what I'm
hearing there is you didn't overthink
here's my ICP, here's like the wedge and
the strategy of how we expand into this
large thing. It's like here's people
with a problem that hasn't been solved
in years that we keep seeing let's try
to solve it.
>> Exactly that. And if you if you take
that problem centered approach that
helps people to achieve something they
actually want to do in the real life,
you're probably going to be at a
reasonably good spot. Um especially if
it maps to a larger market, that's a
particularly great thing. you know, if
it only solves one person's problem,
that might not be a great company going
forward. But if a few people have that
same problem, but I think that again,
like back to that big ladder and that
first rung, not getting too I think it's
better to solve a small number of
people's problem really well than trying
to solve a large number of people's
problem not very well at all.
>> Something I can't not ask about is just
how you think about AI in your product.
You mentioned how you integrated or all
through the product. Just, you know, you
guys are doing really good stuff with
AI. A lot of companies are struggling to
find something really that works great.
Do you have do you have just like a
philosophy of here's how we integrate AI
into Canva where it ends up being really
helpful and and people love it? Your
question is actually the answer at the
same time. I think being able to
integrate it into the product where it
actually helps people to get their work
done, where it genuinely helps them to
achieve their goals and then being
really open to listening to your
community and hearing what they're
loving, what they're struggling with and
refining from there, I think is really
really important. Just because AI is all
the rage and investors really like AI
doesn't necessarily mean it should be
front and center um in but if it can
genuinely help your customers to achieve
their goals. So you know what the thing
that I was mentioning before enabling
people to communicate their ideas and
have little friction between those two
points. AI is just kind of like you know
naturally a very critical part of that
equation for us. In fact it was funny
looking back from really old decks. We
were trying to do AI before AI was
actually a thing because it really was
critical to what we were trying to do.
Even in our 2012 deck you can kind of
imagine how AI very much fit into the
equation because of exactly what we were
trying to do. I'm going to keep us on
the AI thread and take us to AI corner,
which is a recurring segment on this
podcast. So, here's the question. What's
a way you've found in your personal life
and work life to use AI where it ends up
being really helpful, something really
interesting that people might find
useful?
>> So many things. So, AI is often the
first if I'm like having an idea, it'll
be the first place that I go and explore
the idea. And now with Canva, and you
can just tag Canva, I can say, "Give me
more ideas of this." and it's like
shockingly great because it has all of
the context from the design is actually
integrated deeply into your workflow.
Uh, another really fun thing I do um is
an AI walk and it's when I just put my
um ear pods in and then I go for a walk
and I just say everything on my mind and
it I use that to then kind of filter out
my thoughts and figure out what are the
things I need to action and it kind of
helps again get out of the weeds and
think about things from a more macro
perspective rather than um from the
things that might be in my Slack
messages or on my email. It just gives
you that sort of helpful vantage point I
find. So yeah, so many things
>> for the voice note tool. Is there a tool
that you find useful for that?
>> Yeah, I I might use um Apple Notes or
directly into Canva Docs and then I
actually just do the brain dump into
Canva Docs and then just um do like
summarize it. So yeah,
>> got it. And so you just use like native
uh microphoneation
sort of thing. Nothing fancy.
>> Yeah. Okay. Yeah, I like it. This
reminded me of you mentioned earlier in
our conversation you have this you had
this vision board that you said is like
for 2050. Is that right?
>> Yeah, that's right.
>> Can you share something from that vision
board?
>> I'll tell you why the vision board came
about because it's only been in recent
months.
I did feel like as humanity we are on a
bit of a freight train and that freight
train is I think if we take a lot of
visions for a lot of different companies
and a lot of things that are happening
and you just fast forward 50 years or
maybe to 2050 and you say are we in a
safer world is the world the place that
we want our kids to grow up in is this
the humanity that we want
I didn't feel that the train that we are
headed on always feels great In fact, it
it scared me quite greatly um for a
whole host of reasons. And so
I sat with that feeling for a little and
then I kind of got to work on my 2050
wall and you know back to the chaos to
clarity. The first thing was writing my
2050 wall and I've kind of really been
loving I've got a whole on the 2050 wall
started with a lot of quotes. um
everything good was uh once imagined
and many other quotes along those
similar lines. And then rather than just
being fearful of the things that I'm
worried about for society and for
humanity, I started to think like what
would the alternative be? What is that
vision that I would love to see us have?
You know, basic human needs for all. Um
you know, global education being a basic
human right that everyone experiences.
um all the really important things that
we want as humanity and again like using
vision and using imagination and just
dreaming about the future. And I find it
really fascinating in my dayto-day by
literally having it beside me as I work
every day. The little tiny decisions
that can kind of help to angle towards
that future that we want. And
can I help will any of that into
existence? I honestly don't know. But I
feel like just by starting to write it
down, I done a little brainstorm
exercise with a number of other people
and starting to just like etch out like
how do we get closer and closer to that?
You know, on my vision of the future,
it's community. It's the whole of
humanity trying to dream bigger and to
dream bigger goals and then us rising to
that occasion. You in the in the world
we don't want. I think loneliness is
rough. Purpose is gone. what we teach
people in schools is pointless. And in
my vision for 2050, it's none of those
things. You know, communities are
bountiful. We all have deep purpose and
that deep purpose springs from having
bigger dreams that we collectively go
out and achieve. with something that
we're doing um at our Canva world tour
keynote in two weeks time which I think
is going to be after this is released um
we've been asking people what is one
goal you'd like to see the world
achieved in our lifetime and then people
literally writing it down I think is
pretty powerful and then people sharing
that with other people I think is pretty
powerful and then us actually figuring
out how the hell do we turn that reality
that we all deeply desperately want into
existence I think is genuinely one the
biggest questions of our time. But then
again, rather than trying to tackle that
entire thing by yourself, how do you
take that first tiny step that starts to
see that in your own life, in your own
family, in your own community? Um, and I
think that's where we'll get purpose
from. And that's, you know, I think that
is one of the key answers to loneliness
is actually working towards something
bigger than yourself.
>> Wow. I really appreciate you sharing all
that. Uh I was thinking as you're
talking just considering how wildly
successful Canva has been and just how
ambitious that was when you started I
would not be at all surprised that uh
this actually happens and you achieve
this very difficult vision.
>> It's not something that I alone can
achieve. I think we it it has to be
obviously a global collective effort
because there's zero chance I can go and
achieve basic human needs for all. But I
think that I'd like to change that. I'd
like to help change the mood. I'd like
to help change the the way we're
thinking about things. Um I I genuinely
think there's a little we need to move
course a little and decide not what what
are all the things that we kind of like,
you know, what what's the freight train
we're currently on, but what is it that
we actually want? What do we want our
societies to look like? What do we want
the world to look like? Is it good
enough that there's people hundreds of
millions of people that can't eat? Like
what the hell? Like it just literally
makes no sense.
>> Uh a column B world you might say.
>> Absolutely.
>> Melanie, this was incredible.
Before we get to our very exciting
lightning round, is there anything else
that you wanted to share? Anything else
you want to leave listeners with?
>> Oh, you have been extremely extensive. I
don't think I've got anything else to
[laughter] add, frankly.
>> That's the goal. That's the goal. With
that, we've reached our very exciting
lightning round. Melanie, are you ready?
>> Let's go.
>> First question. What are two or three
books that you find yourself
recommending most to other people?
>> One of the books I love is The Power of
Moments. And it talks Am I supposed to
be really fast and not tell you about
it?
>> It's it's all good.
>> Okay. Two two books. The Power of
Moments and um one of the books early on
I read was Designing the Obvious, which
I found very insightful.
>> Okay. I like they shifted to fast mode.
You don't have to go super fast. All
good. What is a favorite product you've
recently discovered that you really
love? Not Canva. I love the car app. It
is my daily companion. I use it to
meditate. I, you know, use it to listen
to music. I just find it very calming.
>> Okay. First question I usually ask about
movies and TV shows. I hear you don't
watch a lot because you're so busy and
have so much going on. So, I'm going to
try a new question. Okay. I haven't
asked before. I'm curious where this
goes. So, excluding Canva. What's a
product you'd love to work on someday?
Whether it's like an existing other
company like, "Oh, I wish I could work
on that thing." or just a new product
you'd love to build maybe after the
Canva chapter.
>> I feel like my Canva chapter is going to
go on for a long time. So, I don't know
that because you got two plans pretty
pretty extensive.
>> Maybe a company you'd love to fund.
There we go.
>> I feel like there is a lot of
opportunity to create um global
infrastructure that is truly empowering.
And so as I look at my 2050 wall, I
think there's a lot of things that are
currently only exclusively available to
a small number of people that should be
available to everyone. And so the more
that we can do to uplift, you know, the
rising tide lifts all boats, I think is
a thing that's just so of such critical
importance. And I think there is this
weird belief that you can be fine and
everyone else can be not fine and that's
all cool. I don't think that's cool. I
think everyone suffers in such a case.
So I think more things that help
everyone to rise.
>> Maybe along those lines but maybe not.
Is there a life motto that you find
yourself coming back to in work your own
life?
>> There's a few. I love the quote
happiness is when what you think, what
you say, and what you do are in harmony.
I feel like that's a a constant
aspiration.
And then I I've just been so obsessed
lately with the idea that everything is
led by imagination. that imagination is
the very first step of that creative
process. So everything is good was once
imagined is a quote you're going to be
seeing from Canva all the time now
because it it's it is true that if you
don't imagine it, you can't will it into
existence. And in fact, everything great
that we experience in life was first
imagined.
>> Wow. There's so much power to that. One
uh thought nugget there is just there's
all these tools now that can make thing
make building so much easier. You can
just build anything you want. Just
describe it. But so many people are just
like I'm in the same boat. I'm just
stuck. What? What do I want? I don't
even like I don't know what I need. What
What should I build? And that's exactly
what you're talking about there. Okay,
last question. So, I saw somewhere that
you were a aspiring figure skater in
[laughter] your early years in high
school. You had to wake up at 4:30 a.m.
to practice. Uh, is there something you
learned from that period of your life
that was helpful in building Canva?
>> Oh, so many things are quite directly
applicable. falling down over and over
again and getting off and trying again.
Um, the importance of hard work and
determination. I think the falling down
like it was quite literal in my figure
skating in days and maybe it's a little
more metaphorical in in today, but it is
constant.
>> So, you're right. I wonder what that
metaphor is for figure skating. I don't
know. Anyway, Melanie, this was
incredible. I am so thankful that you
agreed to do this. Two final questions.
Where can folks find you if they want to
maybe reach out, send you maybe feedback
on Canva or join Canva? And how can
listeners be useful to you?
>> Really great questions. So, you can find
me on LinkedIn. That's where I post the
most. Um, and you can go to and I can
get the URL to give us your wishes and
we want to hear them and we literally
listen to them. It doesn't just go into
a suggestion box. [laughter] Um, and
then how can they be helpful? Um, use
Canva, spread Canva, teach Canva. Um,
we're doing a Canva world tour in
through October, which is probably gonna
be outdated when this is posted.
Come to our events. We do events all
around the world. Um, and we'd love to
see you and to hear from you. And
if you are in a company, starting a
company, try and do the 1% pledge. Try
and figure out your own version of the
two-step plan and try and build
products. And [snorts] in every decision
that you make that actually makes the
world that you want to live in. I think
there's this kind of belief sometimes
that the world is created by other
people but we all have a very active
hand in the creating the world that we
live in and you know every decision that
you make every for investors every
company that you fund is that
contributing the world to the world that
you want to live in or is it creating
the freight train that none of us want
to be on? I have to ask before I let you
go. This uh are you gonna have the rap
dancers at the the next Canva event?
>> You'll have to wait and see. [laughter]
>> Okay, Melanie, thank you so much for
being here.
>> Thank you so much, Lenny, for having me
and your great wellressearched
questions.
>> Thank [laughter] you. Bye, everyone.
Thank you so much for listening. If you
found this valuable, you can subscribe
to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
or your favorite podcast app. Also,
please consider giving us a rating or
leaving a review as that really helps
other listeners find the podcast. You
can find all past episodes or learn more
about the show at lennispodcast.com.
See you in the next episode.